[Musique]
donc
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre est une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé la première grande
manifestation parisienne du 6 février 34
de même pu craindre la disparition de la
toute jeune garde républicaine ou billes
dans la presse s'était déchaînée sur ce
qu'était réellement le noyau dur du
dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 14 décembre
l'ambiguïté entretenue par emmanuel
mètres autour de sa candidature au plus
haut point à quatre mois de la
présidentielle ses opposants l'accusent
de multiplier les déplacements de
campanie d'occuper les plateaux télé
sans être officiellement candidat demain
soir entretien de deux heures sur tf1
lci elle est candidate elle est raide
rip créer c'est le candidat écologiste
yannick jadot demande au csa de rétablir
l'égalité des temps de parole et vous
qu'en pensez vous et magna mais qu'en
est-il plus candidat que président le
débat est ouvert on attend toujours vos
réactions sur notre compte télégramme
le vario mikron se propage toujours à
vitesse grand v partout dans le monde la
nouvelle souche a été détectée dans une
soixantaine de pays la france n'est pas
épargnée avec plus de 130 cas jean
castex et mis en garde aujourd'hui face
à la cinquième vague et parle d'une
sixième bas possible dès janvier paris
envisage des restrictions plus sévères à
la frontière avec le royaume uni
invariants plus contagieux qui inquiète
également aux états unis on fera le
point avec nos journalistes à londres et
à washington
[Musique]
renforcer les alliances des états unis
contre la chine c'est l'objectif d'une
tournée inédite pour anthony blinken en
asie du sud est le chef de la diplomatie
américaine et en malaisie aujourd'hui
direction ensuite la thaïlande hier en
indonésie il a appelé pékin à cesser je
cite c'est être agressive dans la zone
indo pacifique le secrétaire d'état qui
est aussi affirmé l'attachement de
washington à la paix et à la stabilité
dans le détroit de taiwan elle est lisa
suivre dans cette émission
au sommaire à 21h cet appel à la grève
pour le premier week-end des vacances de
noël à la sncf des préavis notamment sur
les tgv sud-est et sud-ouest
les cheminots réclament des
augmentations de salaires ou encore une
prime qu'ovide le gouvernement promet de
son côté minoré au maximum l'impact de
cette grève sur les français alors vous
comprenez où cette colère des cheminots
ont ils raison à deux faire grève avant
les fêtes on attend vos réactions sur
notre compte et d g
[Musique]
emmanuel macron omniprésent sur le
terrain et à la télévision sans se
déclarer candidat un air de pré campagne
du président sortant qui agace fortement
ses opposants une interview enregistrée
et diffusée demain en prime time sur les
chaînes tf1 lci qui provoque la colère
de plusieurs candidats à la
présidentielle
on retrouve notre reporter estelle
farges aux abords de l'elysée bonsoir et
celle alors certains candidats ont donc
décidé de saisir le csa concernant cette
intervention du chef de l'état
et oui stéphanie ils sont deux au moment
où je vous parle à avoir saisi le csa
d'abord valérie pécresse la candidate
lr à la présidentielle l'a annoncé hier
en marge d'un déplacement dans le pas de
calais son entourage la dénonce
d'ailleurs un scandale selon des propos
rapportés par le figaro valérie pécresse
qui devait d'ailleurs demain intervenir
sur une chaîne d'information en continu
al a dû reporter son interview à d'un
commun accord avec la chaîne et puis
deuxième candidat à la présidentielle à
avoir a saisi le csa
yannick jadot le candidat e élevé qui
appelle à ce que la mascarade cesse je
propose à d'écouté que les deux
candidats à la présidentielle
on ne peut pas avoir un président
candidat qui se fait ouvrir les chaînes
de télévision à la demande et pendant
des heures fait sa campagne alors que
ses adversaires doivent se contenter de
cinq minutes duplex pour lui répondre ce
n'est pas ma conception de la démocratie
je demande au csa de rétablir l'égalité
des temps de parole et le fair-play
démocratique le débat républicain mérite
mieux que deux heures d'une interview du
président candidat sur tf1 et les autres
candidats renvoyé au rôle de
commentateur je saisi le csa l'équité
est un principe fondamental de la
démocratie
la mascarade doit cesser
globalement les oppositions de droite
comme de gauche dénoncent cette
intervention à télévisée du chef de
l'état mais l'exhortent aussi à mettre
fin à l'ambiguïté autour de ça quand
probable candidature à sa propre
succession
la majorité elle fait front à derrière
emmanuel macron c'est bien comme un
président qu'il s'exprimera demain soir
a indiqué le ministre des relations avec
le parlement qui pointe aussi je cite en
énerve inutile de la part de la droite
merci et self argent direct de l'elysée
vous l'aurez compris l'interview
télévisée du président passe mal en
pleine campagne présidentielle ses
opposants lui demandent de mettre fin à
un secret de polichinelle
un vrai faux suspens alors emmanuel
macron est il plus candidat que
président houphouët il dut en même temps
le débat est ouvert en étant toujours
vos réactions sur notre compte
télégramme d'ayrté france et c'est lors
du décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pourrons parler sur ce
plateau gilles casanova spécialiste en
communication politique bonsoir gilles
casanova merci d'être avec nous à vos
côté alexis poulain à bonne distance
bonsoir alexis poule invitant à l'iss rt
france merci d'être là et puis avec nous
en direct aussi pour nous accompagner
philippe gosselin député l ère de la
manche bonsoir avoue vincent chauvet
également maire modem d'autun
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous de également
alors une réaction à cette polémique ça
parle depuis hier la classe politique
est en gros mise à part le modem et ella
rae mme van den boer depuis l'annoncé
par tf1 de cette émission spéciale en
prime time l'opposition fustige cette
intervention l'a entendu c'est une
interview alexis d'un candidat non
déclaré c'est tout le problème le
problème il est il est multiple le
problème c'est que et mener le maquereau
on ne peut pas passer une semaine sans
capter l'attention des médias pour
phagocyter finalement tout ce qui ferait
une campagne présidentielle la semaine
dernière le lendemain deux grands
meetings il arrive pour déambuler à
vierzon et pour sortir un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire bombannes
là cette semaine on est en train de
parler d'autre chose il ya des
déplacements de candidats il a besoin de
deux heures d'interviews de complaisance
sur une chaîne de grande écoute deux
heures une interview enregistrée qui
plus est même pas dans des conditions du
direct la semaine dernière il faisait
une conférence de presse pour parler
de la présidence européenne du conseil
de plo présidence française du conseil
européen je veux dire c'est pas les
candidats dans cette campagne ne joue
pas à armes égales c'est à dire que vous
avez face à vous un président de la
république
omniprésent qui utilisent les médias qui
sont en plus des médias très complaisant
et des candidats qui se battent pour
faire connaître leurs campagnes yannick
jadot il y avait un sondage récemment
qui disait que 50 % des français
interrogés n'était même pas au courant
qu'il était en campagne là vous avez un
président même s'il n'est pas candidat
de toute façon vous l'avez matin midi et
soir à la télévision il est là le
problème il est là le problème c'est que
fondamentalement il ya un problème c'est
totalement déséquilibrée et valérie
pécresse tout comme yannick jadot ont
raison de saisir le csa ce n'est pas
normal que le président utilise des
médias de cette façon là on parle de
propagande ici on parle pas du tout
d'interviews d'un chef de l'état gilles
cazade avant on parle de propagande
avant évidemment d'aller poser la
question aussi aux aux intéressés par ce
que le franc qui dit peu grosse quand ça
va bien énervé aussi cet après midi on
va en parler mais rapidement il ya un
déséquilibre c'est une forme de
propagande et on joue par megal alors la
règle du csa c'est un tiers de temps de
parole pour la majorité un tiers pour
l'opposition
un tiers pour le gouvernement le
président de la république n'est pas
dans les décomptes du csa il parle où il
veut quand il veut autant qu'il veut
cependant lorsque s'ouvre la période
électorale le csa des comptes dans les
propos du président ce qui ressort de
son rôle de président par exemple
'l'annonce d'un confinement ou d'inde et
confinement est ce qui ressort de la
campagne électorale par exemple
l'annnonce de sa vision du monde ce qui
est l'objectif des deux heures qu'il
fait sur tf1 et lci
là on peut considérer que ces deux
heures là elles vont être dans le compte
de campagne s'il est candidat alors
évidemment par exemple françois hollande
n'ayant pas été candidat la partie que
le csa avait retenu est tombé dans la
corbeille mais pour les autres en
général on a fait entrer ce temps mais
il faut avoir en tête la jurisprudence
du csa exprimée par son président en
le csa considère qu'il a des candidats
de premier tour et des candidats de
second tour et
donc le président du csa a dit la veille
du premier tour nous avons fait notre
travail puisque un tiers du temps est
allé à lionel jospin un tiers du temps
est allé à jacques chirac et un tiers du
temps à tous les autres candidats donc
vous voyez comment la méthode du csa qui
a retiré la parole sur la chronique
qu'il faisait à eric zemmour est une
méthode
un peu difficile à cerner alors philippe
gosselin moussant on a vu cet après midi
que ça vous a bien embêtés on a assisté
à ce d'armes l assemblée nationale avec
le porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent je vous laisse découvrir ça avant
de vous donner la parole
cinq ans plus tard ce nouveau monde nous
paraît pire il faut le dire que l'ancien
votre majorité finalement reproduit et
même absent tu tous les travers
politique qu'elle dénonçait hier
l'émission qui sera diffusée demain soir
et bien une émission de campagne ni plus
ni moins personne le citron sauf que le
président refuse de s'appliquer à lui
même les règles sur les temps de parole
puis doivent pourtant respecté tous les
autres candidats monsieur le député
gosselin quand on cherche à convaincre
les français on cherche alors parlez pas
empêché les autres de le faire
quand on cherche à convaincre les
français on cherche la cohérence vous
êtes en train de dire l'exact inverse de
ce que vous disiez il y a dix ans quand
vous défendiez à raison la légitimité du
président sarkozy a parlé de son action
face à la crise jusque tard en 2012
alors philippe gosselin je sais que
richard ferrand ne vous a pas donné le
temps de la troisième réponse à vous
lire voilà donc vous allez avoir la
parole qu'est ce que vous auriez envie
de lui répond en droit gabriel attal à
l'écouter on peut pas dire on empêche le
président de la république de s'exprimer
je crois qu'en ce moment il se
surexprime il se susurre exprime en tant
que président en tant que futur
président
l'europe en tant que candidat qui
annonce 40e de mesures pour 45 milliards
d'euros qui ne sont pas financées il est
présent sur le terrain dans le nord dans
le sud il est partout et
systématiquement à des périodes où les
oppositions en tout cas une partie des
de l'opposition peut s'exprimer donc on
voit bien que tout est fait pour court
circuiter c'est pas un débat d'idées
c'est une omniprésence qui devient
envahissante et on veut aussi dénoncé
finalement une une focalisation des
moyens alors c'est pas c'est pas nouveau
qu'un président ne soit pas encore en
campagne et profite un peu de la
situation c'est ce qui avait amené
valérie pécresse je ne dis pas le
contraire il y a dix ans à défendre
nicolas sarkozy sauf que sauf que le csa
avait introduit dans le temps de parole
du candidat sarkozy par la suite ce
temps de pré campagne parce qu'il le csa
avait estimé que nicolas sarkozy était
candidat présumé et bien écoutez nous on
aimerait que les choses soient claires
et que le président de la république
assume ce qu'il soit clairement
considéré comme candidat présumé ils ne
bénéficient pas de moyens qui prive
finalement l'expression démocratique des
autres candidats ça a été très bien dit
il y à quelques minutes sur votre
plateau c'est totalement déséquilibrée
aujourd'hui vincent chauvet vous venez
d'entendre trois intervenants
effectivement philippe gosselin porte
parole 1 devait libérer près pécresse
pardon qui demande au csa donc de
rétablir clairement l'égalité du temps
de parole ça vous semblerait juste tout
de même
moi je pense que cette position c'est
une double insulte et c'est un procès
d'intention c'est une insulte d'abord
joris de tf1 tf1 c'est un média privé et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ce n'est pas
une télévision d'état une télévision aux
ordres donc ils ont envie de passer le
présent dans le public et le passé j'ai
remarqué
delbos est invité à 14h pour le 20
heures le soir elle a eu libre antenne
dans la journée par ailleurs c'est une
insulte aussi à l'intelligence des
membres du csa une autorité
administrative indépendante
moi je m'étonne qu'une candidats les
républiques anne valérie pécresse tu
fasse pression sur une autorité
administrative indépendante reprendre
décision le csa n'a pas besoin de mines
monsieur jadot ning madame pécresse pour
appliquer son mandat appliquer la loi et
fera ce que la loi est prévu si madame
pécresse ça va donner mais confie pas
pardonnez moi mais c'était quand même
important quand philippe gosselin
rappelle que nicolas sarkozy avait été
considérée par le csa comme un candidat
présumé pourquoi ne pas appliquer la
même règle à emmanuel macron le comme le
csa juin et nicolas sarkozy était
intervenu en janvier est aujourd'hui le
président de la république est décomptée
quand il parle du régalien donc à pas et
quand il parle d'autre chose décomptés
dans le temps de parole de la majorité
gouvernementale
donc il est faux de dire qu'aujourd'hui
le temps de parole de près dans la
public est complètement débridée qui
pourrait exploiter 24 heures sur 24 les
chaînes d'info c'est faux le csa
applique en fonction de l'échéance qui
se rapproche des règles de plus en plus
strictes et à la fin c'est une égalité
stricte sur la période officielle de
campagne on est sur une égalité stricte
entre tous les candidats et c'est l'art
m6 valérie pécresse le change et qu'elle
propose une nouvelle loi c'est parce que
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu des formes de
pression sur le csa et enfin c'est
surtout un procès d'intention parce que
moi personnellement je n'ai pas lu cette
interview personne autour de la table ni
valérie pécresse je pense n'a vu cette
interview et personne ne peut préjuger
de ce que le président de la république
va dire ou à annoncer moi j'ai envie
d'entendre dans une période qui est très
compliquée avec vous avez cité des
tensions géopolitiques importante des
craintes une situation c'était moi j'ai
grandi en tant que citoyen simplement
d'entendre ce que le président a dit on
a soupé pendant un mois de délai matin
midi et soir sur toutes les chaînes
d'info en continu moi j'ai envie
d'entendre que présente la république a
à dire et ensuite le csa à pitre à la
loi et des contrats mais j'ai pas
l'impression que emmanuel macron
squattent les chaînes d'info il fait des
déplacements en province qui sont tout à
fait intéressant par exemple sur le
programme action coeur de ville il
intervient et c'est son rôle dans les
séquences mémorielle dans les
commémorations que nous allons les
hommages nationaux personnes éminentes
décédé et lined exposé c'est bien on
verra ce qu'il ya à dire
appréhender ce qu'il a annoncé on va
vous redonner la parle évidemment
vincent chauvet on va regarder le
premier message télégramme qui nous
parvient luisi 22 arrêtons l'hypocrisie
les autres l'ont fait aussi où le ferai
aussi la question est comment concilier
l'état de candidats et celui de
président tout en restant dans l'équité
peut-être en se déclarant alexis boulin
gens voyaient tous les trois il est vrai
à vincent chauvet faire des petits bons
quand le monde de la majorité nous
exposer ses arguments
rapidement parce que
non mais le problème c'est pas un
problème d'arguties juridiques sur le
travail que fait elle c'est ça ou ne
fait pas le problème il est structurelle
c'est de dire qu'on a en france un
président candidat on n'a pas ce moment
des primaires à l'américaine où de toute
façon le président sortant est obligé de
faire campagne là on se retrouve dans
quelque chose ou non seulement le
président convoque la presse quand il
est en déplacement c'est uniquement pour
prendre la presse à partie pour qu'on
parle de lui les conseils de défense
sanitaire qu'on arrête de me faire
croire que le conseil de lundi n'étaient
pas là pour débrancher les meetings
d'eric zemmour et jean luc mélenchon le
lendemain là c'est pareil deux heures
d'interview sur tf1 c'est une interview
de campagne pour faire le bilan en plus
de son quinquennat seul sens sans que
sont le sens conférence de presse c'est
un président qui n'a jamais paf jamais
fait de conférence de presse quasiment 3
conférence de presse pendant cinq ans
c'est du jamais vu c'est à dire qu'il ya
une façon de maltraiter les médias
d'utiliser les médias comme de la
communication comme une agence de com ça
c'est pas possible et en plus ya les
réseaux sociaux et c'est vrai qu'on en
parle parce que le csa n'a aucune
juridiction là dessus et le maquereau a
très bien dit tik tok instagram les
réseaux pour la jeunesse sont la clé
aussi de cette élection et d'autres
candidats essayent de jouer sur ces
réseaux sociaux et là il n'ya pas de
décompte de temps de parole et c'est
pareil c'est l'omniprésence donc il faut
vraiment
à un moment de trouver de nouvelles
règles du jeu et puis ne pas être dupes
les journalistes de tf1 sont très
contents d'avoir emmanuel macron
évidemment c'est le prix dans la
république mais on est en campagne on
est en temps de campagne donc c'est tout
à fait différent quand tant de
quinquennat où il serait là pour
s'expliquer sur ce qui s'est passé cette
année gilles casanova justement vous
êtes communiquant politique vous lui
auriez conseillé à emmanuel a construit
que vous avez été dans son équipe deux
justement enregistré cette émission et
surtout la sphère diffusé le jour où
valérie pécresse était supposé être sur
une autre chaîne à la lieu d'ailleurs se
décaler de lui alors si j'étais
conseiller je dirais qu'il faut pas
faire écrire les éléments de langage par
les gens qui les prononce seront jamais
parce qu'ensuite ceux qui les prononcent
ont du mal à le faire et du mal à être
crédible pour défendre le président mais
ce que je voudrais dire c'est qu'ils
allaient texte et ya la vie les textes
disent que le président ne doit pas
abuser voilà en gros ce qui est écrit
alors les précédents présidents ils ont
passé leur temps un peu sur la frontière
c'était discutable est ce que là c'était
plus est ce que là c'était moins alors
le csa disait bam là c'est un peu trop
donc on vous retire
là on est plus sur la frontière on est
carrément dans le pays un pays d'à côté
où on a installé son équipement et son
aéroport donc on est au delà de tout ce
qui n'est jamais arrivé donc
ou bien le csa considère qu'on est dans
le nouveau monde et que donc tout ça
fait partie de la nouvelle vie ou bien
on considère qu' il faut intervenir pour
dire où est la limite où est la
frontière dans une zone qui est toujours
naturellement un peu grise mais qui ne
peut pas être à ce point rouge vif est
philippe gosselin où il envoyait réagir
aux propos de richard casanova
oui oui je je je partage totalement
enfin quand le maire d'hôteliers qu'on
fait pression sur le csa parce que nous
saisissons le csa je lui rappelle que le
rôle d'une autorité administrative
indépendante c'est aussi de pouvoir être
saisi c'est aussi de pouvoir inscrire un
certain nombre de plaques c'est c'est
son rôle c'est très clair dont il ya
aucune pression le csa est à une grande
fille qui sera capable ou une grande
institution qui sera capable de se
déterminer on verra ce qu'il en sera
maintenant il n'y a pas de pression il
ya un cadre juridique mais vous
conviendrez qu'il ne s'agit pas
simplement de ce cadre juridique et
qu'il ne s'agit pas non plus d'entendre
le président de la république sur sa
vision de l'inde au pacifique l'émission
est bien présenté comme un bilan le une
ans et celui d'un sortant c'est pas du
tout ce que vous nous vendez alors
certes je n'ai pas vu l'émission
puisqu'elle est enregistrée soit disant
dans les conditions du direct très bien
et vous voyez bien que ce n'est pas la
même chose d'avoir une émission
enregistrée dans les conditions du
direct une émission en direct ça veut
dire que certains aujourd'hui ont déjà
l'ensemble des éléments que les éléments
de langage peuvent être largement
distribués pour que en temps réel soit
démultiplier servent à illustrer donc on
est encore moins sur un pied d'égalité
d'abord sur le fond il s'agit bien de
défendre un bilan un bilan avec 72
heures d'avancé pour des participants et
puis bah les autres qui vont devoir se
contenter de découvrir la règle du jeu
en cours de partie moi je n'appelle pas
ça un match à la loyale je suis désolé
vincent changé c'est vrai que le type de
l'émission sait où va la france on ne
sent pas vraiment
voilà comment dirais-je il ya
effectivement ambiguïté non déjà une
différence entre bilan et promesses on
le sait quand on délivre locaux lé bilan
de mandat sont autorisés c'est pas la
même chose que des promesses de campagne
est là et bien il n'est pas en train de
détailler son programme pour 2022 moi je
souhaite évidemment qu'il soit candidat
mais il ya une différence entre un bilan
et des propositions de campagne et que
leur président fasse un retour objectifs
sur ces différentes actions ça ne paraît
pas complètement anodin
il a ensuite le bleu je le redis c'est
ça n'a pas besoin des républicains pour
faire appliquer la loi à ces cétacés de
la beuze de la communication j'espère
qu'on en parle également ce sujet et
puis enfin en france on convoque pas la
presse on invite la presse la presse
n'est pas aux ordres ne convoque pas et
je ne sais pas sur quelle planète vit
votre et au réalisme j'ai l'impression
que les réseaux sociaux et par emmanuel
mais nous on aimerait bien être invité
grt façon lance un appel à emmanuel
macron est d'ailleurs à tous les autres
candidats alexis poulain c'est vrai que
on n'a pas cette chance sur arte france
d'être non invité par l'elysée lors de
mes pistes extrêmes de ces en tri c'est
vrai que c'est
et voilà on imagine que le travail va
être ardue pour les membres du csa
d'examiner chaque parole parce que
l'équipe de communication de l'elysée va
forcément faire un effort pour masquer
une forme de bilan ou de houe de
campagne n'est ce pas évidemment tout
est fait pour faire passer cette
émission pour une émission hommage un
quasiment hommage à emmanuel macron
pourquoi pas tant qu'on y est avec
stéphane bern qui va nous parler mais
c'est pas nouveau moi moi j'ai en tête
cette interview au pied du sapin de noël
sur le service public bayou et moselle
mc on faisait visiter l'elisée je crois
que c'était la première année de son
quinquennat là aussi on était dans la
géographie ways facetté c'était pas le
rôle d'un média de faire ce type de
reportage avec emmanuel macron on est
toujours dans la communication dans
l'utilisation médiatique à des fins de
propagande politique et c'est là où
effectivement le csl totalement
désemparés dans
c'est pas du tout le sol nicolas sarkozy
avait fait nicolas sarkozy télé
lorsqu'il était en campagne lui aussi
avait un rapport aux médias très très
très charnelle très proche françois
hollande qui a invité les journalistes à
l'elysée pour parler et raconter tout et
n'importe quoi donc il ya toujours eu un
rapport particulier mais là on sent
l'utilisation de communicationnel c'est
à dire qu'on sait très bien que ce
président est en campagne c'est inutile
de faire croire qu'il ne va pas être
candidat face à me paraît quand même du
domaine de l'impossible on sait jamais
après tout la politique s'est jamais
comme prévu mais là on est vraiment dans
quelque chose doute c'est ça et
forcément désemparés parce que comme je
disais il ya à la fois les réseaux
sociaux à la fois une communication
multicanal et le jeu est totalement
déséquilibré je suis désolé une élection
présidentielle c'est quel candidat a été
le plus vu par les français finalement
très peu de français connaissent le
l'ensemble des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle gilles casanova je voyais
réagir mais c'est de bonne guerre
si on était à la place emmanuel macron
certainement qu'on ferait la même chose
c'est ben non non parce que c'est de
mauvaise guerre pour une raison que je
vais vous donner c'est que lorsqu'on a
l'impression que le grand dans la cour
d'école maternelle ils frappent tous les
petits un parent parce qu'ils sont
petits eh bien on finit par ne plus
aimer du tout le grand est c'est pas le
droit de le faire ma foi si on a le
droit de le faire oui mais on a aussi le
droit de détester celui qui fait ce
qu'il a le droit le faire mais qui est
immoral donc si j'étais son conseiller
je lui dirai il y a une limite au-delà
de laquelle ça se voit alors il ya david
loosli en même temps il est le seul à
pouvoir défendre son bilan bon ça c'est
pas un partisan d' emmanuel macron
qu'iggy nous qui nous écrit ce
télégramme philippe josselin gosselin
pardon
clairement ça va perturber valérie
pécresse ou ou dans le fond ça vous
arrange un petit peu que de voir que le
président réagi parce que c'est ce que
vous nous dites ans qu'il réagit
justement la montée dans les sondages de
votre candidate plusieurs plusieurs
degrés de lecture d'abord il ya sur le
plan de l'immédiateté une conséquence
directe c'est la déprogrammation d'un
d'une émission qui était prévu sur une
sur une autre chaîne donc on s'est quand
même fâché maintenant en réalité on voit
bien la grande fébrilité qui est
derrière tout cela on a une candidature
de valérie pécresse qui n'était pas du
tout attendu toute la stratégie
élyséenne était de miser sur xavier
bertrand les l'organisation était parti
dans ce sens là et on le sait on a des
contacts avec un certain nombre de
collègues qui nous confirme on a un
certain nombre de papiers qui dans la
presse vont dans le même sens aussi donc
voilà ils sont à l'elysée un peu un peu
déboussolé un peu inquiet donc on sent
bien cette petite fébrilité maintenant
vous savez une fébrilité de noël ne fait
pas l'hirondelle il pas temps donc je me
garderai bien de vous dire que les
choses sont gagnées mais là où il y a
quelque chose de bien gagner c'est que
enfin l'elysée se retrouve avec une
candidature sérieuse qui est prise au
sérieuse et qui va nécessiter un vrai
débat jack maintenant on attend nous a
un match à la loyale ça sera au plus
tard le 1er janvier même si encore une
fois je conteste cette approche je
rappellerai que l'élection
présidentielle a été avancé de plus de
trois semaines par rapport à celle de
2017 et si les règles de 2017 commencer
à s'appliquer au 1er janvier il serait
logique qu'elle s'applique aujourd'hui
trois semaines en amont c'est à dire en
réalité ozanon plan du 1er décembre et à
ce moment là le csa ne pourrait que
constater que le temps de parole de
demain soir est intégrée dans le temps
de parole du candidat vincent chauvet
sur la première partie de la réponse de
philippe gosselin c'est l'illustration
d'une forme de fébrilité du côté de
l'elysée par rapport à la devant la
candidature de valérie pécresse
donc je suis d'accord avec philippe
gosselin valérie pécresse est une
candidate tout à fait sérieuse et il
faudra que vienne le temps du débat
effectivement à armes égales on a vu qu
emmanuel macron en débat notamment face
à marine le pen a été célébré comme le
meilleur candidat je pense que emmanuel
macron en débats face à des candidats de
premier ou deuxième tour sera également
en capacité j'observe que d'autres débat
s'organise notamment à l'extrême droite
c'est là où nous allons avoir le vrai
débat démocratique aujourd'hui
effectivement à part des déclarations
des uns et des autres ou des prime time
la calda socialiste un livre où valérie
pécresse visiblement à déprogrammer mais
en accord avec la chaîne pour se re
programmer plus tard chacun fait surtout
ça ça sa promotion ou en tout cas son
propre discours la démocratie c'est
aussi le temps de les changer j'espère
qu'il viendra et il revient aux médias
qui encore une fois ne sont pas aux
autres donc on voit pas acquis romain
team pas de passer de ne pas passer tel
ou tel candidat d'organiser les débats
qui intéresseront éclaireront le choix
des français alexis poulain il n'y a pas
un fond de vérité dans ce que nous dit
vincent chauvet dans le fond ça va jouer
les derniers mois donc la polémique n'a
peut-être pas lieu d'être parce que est
ce que les électeurs qui pour l'instant
aussi son ne savent pas forcément pour
qui ils vont voter ce qu'ils vont se
souvenir de cette première par alors ni
de précampagne non ils vont pas s'en
souvenir le problème d'une élection
présidentielle c'est qu'elle se fait
dans une cour de récré de 2/6 vous
demandez à des élèves de 6e quelles sont
les personnalités politiques qu'ils
connaissent ils vont vous en six t4
maximum ces quatre là qu'ils vont faire
l'élection donc c'est quoi ces des
personnalités dont on parle parce qu'ils
sont médiatiques ils sont médiatisés
vous avez beaucoup de petits candidats
ou des candidats qui ont moins de
d'accès aux médias donc même s'ils ne
sont pas convoqués c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui vous les voyez
vous les connaissez qui sont ces
candidats et ça ne va faire qu'empirer
donc cette pré campagne
elle est là pour mithridate et l'opinion
publique pour dire finalement voilà vous
savez que ça va jouer entre ces quatre
personnes et demandé un élève de sixième
si vous n'êtes rien sous la main et vous
dira voilà les quatre qui seront qui
seront dans le lot ce second tour soit
qui feront l'élection c'est comme ça que
ça fonctionne malheureusement gilles
cazade avoir les rajouter peut-être
quelque chose sera justement cette
élection qui base ou au dernier moment
est-ce que ça compte tout ça
écoutez ça compte dans le regard que
l'on porte sur la personnalité et je
pense qu emmanuel macron a maintenant
acquis des idées traits de personnalité
assez marquée pour les français et il ne
devrait pas souligner à ce point ceux
qui sont les plus négatifs merci en tout
cas à tous les quatre messieurs philippe
hergaux ce match il casanova vincent
chauvet et alexis poulain merci d'avoir
été avec nous
et on en vient à la situation sur le
front du coc vide ce matin jean castex
était en déplacement à marseille le
premier ministre appelle et encourage
les français à la vigilance face à
l'épidémie en pleine cinquième vague se
préparer également à l'arrivée d'une
sixième avec omicron le chef du
gouvernement exclut pour l'instant la
fermeture des écoles sauf situation
catastrophique
le mot d'ordre est ce le même
vaccination et troisième dose de rappel
demain quatre cent mille personnes âgées
de plus de 65 ans sont menacés de perdre
leur passé des terres faute d'un
troisième vaccin anti qu'ovide leur qr
code sera activé de leur troisième
injection
reçu la troisième dose d'un dossier
actuellement sur la table du régulateur
européen
et après les adultes la vaccination
contre le coc vide sera telle étendue
aux enfants suspens alors que l'on
attend l'avis du comité consultatif
national d'éthique et de la haute
autorité de santé vaccinés les 5-11 ans
le premier ministre s'y est dit
favorable pour limiter la propagation et
la maladie notamment sur ce nouveau
variant les précisions de guillaumin
aussi il est fort possible que d'ici
quelques jours les élèves de cette école
primaire parisienne soit autorisée et
incités à se faire vacciner
des élèves de 5 à 11 ans jusqu'ici
écartés de la campagne de vaccination
sauf pour les profils à risque alors pas
d'injection obligatoire a priori le
conseil scientifique ci est en effet
opposés dans un avis rendu il y a
quelques jours et coûter à ce stade le
conseil scientifique souhaite indiquer
qu'il ne préconise pas que cette
vaccination soit obligatoire ni incluse
dans un éventuel passage iter enfants le
gouvernement est lui favorable à la
vaccination des 5 11 ans une nécessité
selon jean castex une position qui n'est
certainement pas étrangère à la
contamination du premier ministre par sa
fille de 11 ans en novembre dernier la
société française de pédiatrie quant à
elle est plus réservé
l'intérêt est de limiter la contagiosité
limiter la circulation du virus en
vaccinant les jeunes enfants pourquoi
pas mais il faut surtout en priorité
vacciner les adultes pour les protéger
des formes graves le bénéfice de la
vaccination pour les enfants sera
modeste compte tenu du poids de la
maladie qu'il est aussi dans cette
classe d'âge on sait en effet que les
plus jeunes s'ils peuvent transmettre le
virus sont bien moins susceptibles de
développer une forme grave de la maladie
cela a été rappelé et expliquée par une
récente étude de l'inserm publiée le
mois dernier en fait également rappelé
par le conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale qui a publié le 6
décembre dernier un avis prudemment
favorable à la vaccination des enfants
écoutez si les arguments en défaveur de
la vaccination des enfants âgés de 5 à
11 ans appelle à la prudence le conseil
considère que le cumul des trois
bénéfices de la vaccination des enfants
protection individuelle bénéfices
scolaire contrôle de la circulation
virale dépasse les risques potentiels
toutefois ils conditionnent la mise en
place de la vaccination des enfants âgés
de 5 à 11 ans à l'obtention de données
qui assure que la balance bénéfices
risques est favorable en clair vérifier
les effets de la vaccination chez les
enfants là où elle a déjà été mis en
place notamment aux états unis depuis
six semaines maintenant israël mais
aussi plusieurs pays européens ont lancé
ou s'apprête à lancer la vaccination des
5 11 ans comme l'espagne l'autriche
l'italie ou le portugal et la france
devraient vraisemblablement leur
emboîter le pas dans les prochaines
semaines et le variant omicron se
propage également de manière
exponentielle au royaume uni le
gouvernement se retrouve dans
l'obligation de réagir et encourage la
vaccination les précisions de la
correspondante pour r t on au royaume
uni et chats lien edwards
la
dernière visite du premier ministre pour
la nation s'est faite votre rappel
maintenant l'objectif est que la
totalité des adultes du pays a reçu le
rap est d'ici à la fin du mois c'est
plutôt ambitieux cela représenterait un
million de doses par jour je me trouve
devant l'hôpital saint thomas dans le
centre ville de londres comme vous
pouvez le voir la file d'attende se fait
très longue ce matin le nhs demande
d'ailleurs maintenant de ne plus essayer
de prendre rendez-vous en ligne le
système est complètement débordé et
pourquoi une telle accélération du
programme de rappel maintenant d'après
le ministre de la santé le vallon mikron
est désormais le vaillant gueuler n'ont
aucun autre variante ne s'était propagé
aussi rapidement omicron devrait devenir
le variantes de covile 19 dominante dans
la capitale dans les prochaines 48
heures
le mot d'ordre cette semaine est faite
votre rappel maintenant cela rentre
également dans le cadre des restrictions
antico vide du plan b sur lequel le
parlement doit se prononcer ce soir il
prenant le retour de l'obligation de
port du masque le pasco vider les règles
d'isolement mais également la mesure la
plus controversée la vaccination
obligatoire pour les professionnels de
la santé pour de nombreux membres du
public il s'agit d'une atteinte aux
libertés civiques et certains députés
sont du même avis on s'attend donc à une
large fronty les tories beaucoup disent
que forcer la population à se faire
vacciner c'est allé trop loin et c'est
sans parler des mesures d'urgence
temporaire qui ne semble plus si
temporaire que ça
on nous avait dit que ces mesures
pourraient bien être levée avant que le
père noël monde dans son traîneau et
certainement avant que la moitié du pays
ne soit envoyé au goulag il n'y a pas de
répit dans cette logique
autodestructrice et dystopique
gouvernement a placé la responsabilité
sur le public en disant que chacun mais
c'est un message difficile à avaler pour
la population surtout après les
révélations des dernières semaines
certains politiques ne semblent pas
jouer leur rôle pour surmonter la
pandémie non je parle des fêtes de noël
à downing street qui font les gros
titres
mais vous voyez là files d'attentes
derrière moi beaucoup de gens respectent
les règles veulent recevoir leur
rappelle maintenant peut-être dans un
ultime effort pour sauver noël
est à noter que le parlement britannique
vient d'approuver à plus de cent voix
les restrictions nouvelles contre le coc
vide en autriche à présent après le
dernier ont finement la vie reprend peu
à peu son cours les magasins ont rouvert
leurs portes hier et une levée des
restrictions partout dans le pays mais
qui ne concerne que les personnes
vaccinées cyrielle bruit
la valse des achats de noël peut enfin
commencer après trois semaines de
confinement les autrichiens étaient
nombreux ce lundi à se presser devant
les devantures des magasins
je comprends qu'ils aient fermé je suis
heureux qu'il soit nouveau ouvert je
pense aussi que c'est un certain risque
mais on ne veut pas rater des courses de
noël
nous allons regarder les vitrines
pendant un moment et puis nous y
réfléchirons mais en général c'est bien
qu'il y ait la possibilité de faire du
shopping
nous en sommes heureux le denim
vous attendez je vais me faire vacciner
maintenant c'est plus agréable en ville
maintenant il ya plus de gens autour et
c'est plus confortable
donc mais j'ai mon rendez vous
maintenant
la vaccination condition sinequanone
pour profiter de la levée des
restrictions
l'autriche a rétabli la règle dite de g
comprenez vaccinés ou guéries et le port
du masque ffp2 interviewé ce dimanche
par un journal local le chancelier
autrichien karl n'est ameur a insisté
sur l'importance des règles strictes et
contrôlables pour les réunions et
événements une réouverture du pays en
demi teinte qui pourrait renforcer les
tensions ce week end ils étaient des
milliers dans plusieurs villes
autrichiennes a défilé pour dénoncer la
vaccination obligatoire et les
restrictions envers les non vaccinés
brownie tennis
il n'est pas nécessaire d'exclure ceux
qui ne sont pas vaccinés en particulier
les enfants je trouve que c'est une
discrimination incroyable de ne pas
pouvoir envoyer un enfant de 12 ans à la
danse au tennis ou à la piscine parce
que ses parents estiment qu'il est
légitime de ne pas le vexer
[Musique]
en autriche près de 68% de la population
est entièrement vacciner un des taux les
plus faibles d'europe à partir du 1er
février prochain les autrichiens de 14
ans et plus auront pour obligation
d'être vaccinées dans le cas contraire
il risque une amende pouvant aller
jusqu'à 3600 euros
quant au vaccin rue spoutnik v il est
toujours dans l'attenté d'une
certification de l'om est celle
semblerait qu'il est
ailier un malentendu entre moscou et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
russie aide mais avoir mal compris les
demandes de l'om est un bec services
utilisés aujourd'hui en tout cas par
plusieurs dizaines de pays une fiabilité
validé par la prestigieuse revue
médicale the lancet t notamment pour
contrer le nouveau variant omicron les
détails avec notre correspondante mais
lisez ce trait à moscou
scotty lever de nouveau à l'étude son
concepteur examine en effet actuellement
à quel point le vaccin protège contre le
variant au micro les premiers résultats
de ces études devraient être publiés la
semaine prochaine dans le cas où le
vaccin originale ne serait pas assez
efficace une modification à d'ores et
déjà été mise au point la première phase
des essais cliniques est en cours quelle
que soit la dangerosité du nouveau
variant la russie est prête d'après le
kremlin à faire face à une éventuelle
surcharge des hôpitaux
non
il est préférable d'espérer le meilleur
une mais de se préparer au pire voilà ça
doit être notre credo ce qui concerne la
préparation vous savez que grâce au
travail au centre gouvernemental
nous avons toute la logistique prête à
une pression extrême sur le système de
santé et la dernière vague nous l'avons
traversé avec succès de même que la
vague précédente
envoyé que beaucoup d'expérience a été
accumulé
les points de vue diamétralement
opposées chez les scientifiques montrent
que ce variant n'a pas encore été
suffisamment étudiée
il reste donc encore du travail à faire
pour comprendre si c'est dangereux on
peut tisser curatif
si ces meurtriers ou non
par ailleurs des progrès pourraient
bientôt être enregistrées dans le
processus de reconnaissance de spoutnik
départ l'om est une équipe de
représentants de l'organisation en
russie est en effet attendu pour le mois
de janvier d'après le kremlin moscou
doit encore fournir à l oms plusieurs
informations nécessaires à
l'homologation
c'est un sujet important
il y à un travail en cours je vous ai
déjà expliqué
il ya en effet des informations qu'il
faut présenter en vue de la
certification ne l'avons pas encore fait
parce que nous avions une perception
différente des informations qu'il
fallait présenter et de la manière dont
il faut le faire nous avons des
standards différents
nous nous adaptons donc petit à petit à
ses exigences ses exigences ce concerne
absolument tout le monde je le répète
encore une fois nous espérons que ce
travail aura un résultat positif
en ce qui concerne les derniers chiffes
les contaminations continue de baisser
avec un peu plus de 28 mille nouveaux
cas enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures
contre plus de 30000 il ya une semaine
le nombre de décès lui continue a aussi
entre 1100 et 1200 avec 1145 décès
recensés ces dernières 24 heures
et direction présent les états unis ou
le cap des 50 millions de contaminations
encore un virus a été franchie le pays
semble payer son retard dans la
vaccination on en parle avec thomas
bonne et notre correspondant à
washington bonsoir thomas et pour en
quelque sorte un montrer l'exemple les
états unis ont donc décidé de faire le
ménage dans l'armée et renvoyer ceux qui
ont désobéi à l'obligation de se faire
vacciner
il s'agit des premiers exemples de
sanctions au sein de l'armée américaine
ils sont 27 membres de l'ue sr force à
avoir été écarté faute de s'être fait
vacciner le motif invoqué est le refus
d'obéir à un ordre puisqu'il désormais
obligatoire pour les forces armées
américaines de se faire vacciner la
deadline en ce qui concerne l' us here
for n'ai pas eu assez forts s'étaient
fixé au 2 novembre dernier et selon les
données officielles 1000 membres de
l'armée de l'air américaine ont refusé
de se faire vacciner et 4700 ont déposé
une demande d'exemption pour motifs
religieux les autres branches de l'armée
américaine risque d'être confronté très
rapidement à la même situation puisque
les deadline pour la vaccination ont été
fixées là aussi dans le courant du mois
de novembre où le mois de décembre alors
le pentagone dit que 97% des soldats en
activité ont reçu au moins une injection
le problème concerne en fait davantage
les réservistes ou les membres de la
garde nationale puisque si on les ajoute
au total des militaires en service alors
le taux de vaccination chute à 74% soit
environ la même proportion que dans le
reste de la population adulte aux états
unis alors certains vous le savez
s'offusque de cette décision du
pentagone d'avoir imposé la vaccination
à tous les membres des forces armées et
comme souvent cela devient un combat
politique aux états unis vous avez par
exemple le gouverneur républicain de
l'oklahoma ainsi que le procureur
général de cet état qui ont déposé une
plainte au niveau fédéral pour contester
la légitimité de cette mesure une
demande a même été fait pour ne pas
sanctionner les membres de la garde
nationale de l'oklahoma qui n'ont pas
été vaccinés une requête qui a été
rejetée par le gouvernement américain
qui a même menacé de couper les
financements alloués à la garde
nationale de l'eau thomas pour lutter
contre le coc vider avec la propagation
du variant au micro new york et la
californie ont décidé de rétablir dès
demain le port du masque en intérieur
oui des décisions qui sont présentés
comme temporaire dans ces deux états
alors en californie comme dans l'état de
new york cette obligation ne sera en
vigueur nous dit-on que jusqu'au 15
janvier prochain pour l'instant l'idée
pour eux est de contenir la hausse du
nombre contact de contamination et
surtout d'éviter de nouvelles
restrictions écouté par exemple les
arguments de la gouverneur de l'état de
new york
wanna go back je ne veux pas qu'on
revienne un jour à la situation où les
gens ne pouvaient pas aller au travail
sans danger ne pouvait pas se rassembler
les enfants ne pouvaient pas aller à
l'école cet isolement a eu un effet
dévastateur sur la condition humaine et
nous devons encore en gérer les
conséquences aujourd'hui donc pour
éviter cette situation
j'annonce ce jour la mise en place de
l'obligation du port du masque en
intérieur dans tout l'état sauf pour les
établissements ayant mis en place une
obligation de vaccination
un retour du port du masque dans ces
deux états qui ont connu une forte
hausse du nombre de contaminations par
exemple en californie + 47 % du nombre
de cas depuis cinq ving on sait aussi
que ces deux états ont été parmi elles
ceux qui ont pris les mesures les plus
restrictives pendant cette pandémie de
kobe 19 et puis notez que certains ont
quand même décidé à priori de changer
complètement de stratégie le gouverneur
démocrate du colorado estime que l'état
d'urgence est désormais terminée dans
son état même avec l'émergence du
variant omikron il affirme en effet que
les habitants ont eu maintes fois
l'occasion d'être vacciné et que ceux
qui ont refusé doivent désormais en
assumer les conséquences c'est leur
propre faute c'est ce qu'il a déclaré à
la radio d'une radio du colorado
justement merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington et pendant ce temps le
chef de la diplomatie yémen est en
tournée en asie du sud-est anthony
blinken et en mai daisy aujourd'hui se
rendra ensuite en thaïlande pendant son
passage hier en indonésie il a appelé la
chine à cesser je cite ces actes
agressifs dans la région en dopa syfy
qu'écouter
il s'agit de faire respecter les droits
et les accords qui sont à l'origine de
la période la plus pacifique est la plus
prospère pour cette région c'est
pourquoi nous sommes inquiets des
actions agressives de pékin revendiquant
la mer ouvertes comme la sienne il faut
sans les marchés ouverts par le biais de
subventions à ces entreprises publiques
refusant les exploitations ou réponse
quand les accords pour les pays avec
lesquels il est en opposition politique
vivante se livrant à des activités de
pêche illégale non déclarée et non
réglementée
les pays de la région veulent que ce
comportement change nous aussi plus
c'est pourquoi nous sommes déterminés à
garantir liberté de navigation en mer de
chine méridionale où les actions
agressives de pékin menace le mouvement
de plus de 3000 milliards de dollars de
commerce chaque année
une déclaration d' anthony blinken
condamné ce matin par pékin écoutez
si les états unis comme ils le
prétendent veulent réellement joué un
rôle dans le développement de la région
asie pacifique
ils doivent respecter sincèrement la
structure de coopération régionales
centrée sur l'association des nations de
l'asie du sud-est et de patras et de
lignes idéologiques formé déclic ou
provoqué des confrontations entre
groupes ils doivent respecter les
efforts communs de la chine et de
l'association pour maintenir la paix et
la stabilité dans la mer de chine
méridionale et de base revoyez frais
cabourg des flottes et des avions dans
cette mer il semer le trouble
et on va plus loin avec pierre picard
géopolitologue spécialiste de l'asie
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
indonésie hier malaisie aujourd'hui
thaïlande demain qu'elles ont en quels
sont les enjeux géopolitiques mais aussi
officieux derrière vous il n'ya pas que
la diplomatie chinoise qui voyage à
travers le monde on assiste à un
renouveau de la diplomatie américaine
avec jeu joe biden parce qu'en fait
depuis ce temps une élection finalement
le président américain est assez fidèle
à ses engagements et il veut donner au
peuple américain un nouvel élan alors on
va retrouver une politique
internationale américaine qui va être
proche de celle de john filet radcliffe
qui lui finalement avait essayé
l'hythane des petits conflits qui était
relativement coûteux pour la mairie en
redonnant je dirais un espoir au peuple
américain il y aura les mots il n'y aura
peut-être pas les actions c'est une
stratégie à risque parce que à l'époque
lorsque les etats-unis se sont affrontés
avec l'ex s est bien les rapports de
force était différent l amérique était
puissante aujourd'hui ces différentes
l'objectif pour baden c'est de reprendre
du terrain au niveau international et
d'occuper la scène orientale mais à vie
pacifique où la chine est bien implanté
alors justement la chine ont entendu ça
sa réponse ce sont vraiment deux visions
qui s'affrontent oui alors clairement on
peut réaliser aujourd'hui que dans cette
période d'après qu'ovide espérer que on
démarre une nouvelle ère cette nouvelle
situation internationale va créer deux
blocs principaux le bloc des pays qui
seront proches de l'otan et des états
unis et le bleu qui sera plus ou moins
proche des notamment la fédération de
russie et puis de la chine et puis nous
aurons un troisième bloc qui va se
développer qui seront des pays tiers
africains ou autres qui ne veulent pas
se situer dans je dirais dans ce combat
dans cette dualité mais c'est un
véritable risque pour l'amérique parce
que si globalement les états unis ont
réussi
entre guillemets à gagner je dirais le
pari d'état dans le communiste le
communisme pardon de l'ex urss il est
pas du tout évident qu'avec le poids
économique de la chine aujourd'hui
primordiale et de premier rang qu'elle
arrive aux mêmes effets donc on assiste
vraiment à un renouveau de la du
déploiement international des etats-unis
mais il est pour plusieurs années mais
il n'est pas évident que les états unis
gagnent sur ces terrains puisque en fait
les financent également l'économie c'est
aussi bien du côté de pékin oui pékin et
l'asie de sud-est en général qui vous
l'avenir un objet de toutes les
convoitises des états unis aussi de la
russie on peut se demander quelle est la
place de l'europe dans tout ça alors
c'est une excellente question parce que
l'europe sur ces sujets et de par son
histoire et toujours été divisés en tout
cas beaucoup plus neutre au regard des
autres pays avec une politique en tout
cas multilatérale pour certains et pour
la france et c'est vrai que qu'on le
voit pour le cas des jeux olympiques qui
ont été politisée et on se sert du
prétexte car c'est un prétexte de la
démocratie qu'à la chine démocratie et
bien c'est un combat en fait où l'europe
pour a du mal à se situer et je pense
qu'on aura non pas des divisions
majeures mais il y aura forcément des
débats intenses au sein de l'union
européenne pour savoir comment on se
positionne ses sept ans sept à cause de
la division au sein de l'union
européenne qu'on aura du mal à se
positionner vous dites en l'europe oui
en partie et je pense que c'est une des
stratégies de l'administration maiden
qui ne sont point de vue est peut-être
bonne mais peut-être pas au regard de
l'état du monde parce que effectivement
eu secret en opposant à la chine où un
régime important c'est en fait s'allier
des pays partenaires qui eux mêmes en
fait c'est diviser pour régner
donc nous sommes confrontés nous en
europe un choix crucial savoir continuer
nos partenariats avec
les etats unis d'amérique à condition
qu'il n'y ait pas des conditions dès que
ceux de lois extraterritoriales qu'ils
soient trop forte tout en or seulement
ménages en mai en poursuivant notre
coopération avec l'ensemble des pays
pacifiques et avec la chine
aujourd'hui clairement quels sont les
appuis de l'europe dans la région alors
les appuis de rock sont nombreux si on
parle de la convenir de la région asie
pacifique
mais c'est surtout une région qui était
dominé auparavant par les états unis et
aujourd'hui où la chine s'est
considérablement à planter outre le
continent africain donc les je dirais
les étasuniens auront beaucoup de
difficultés sur le plan économique parce
que c'est l'argent la guerre à s'imposer
dans cette région et au risque d'avoir
des débats et des épisodes géopolitique
houleux n'oublions pas que à l'époque de
john fitzgerald kennedy on avait évité
une crise majeure notamment à cuba un
bien effectivement on va vivre des
moments dans cette nouvelle ère des
états unis et de la chine développement
géré pas palpitant mais parfois un petit
peu préoccupants un ma dernière question
aujourd'hui vous voyez
différence majeure entre le style trump
la stratégie en tout cas le style ça
c'est sûr mais la stratégie dans le fond
de trump et il la stratégie aujourd'hui
de l'administration baydan en fait 30 à
essayer de sur les mêmes mobile sur les
mêmes motifs de rassurer le jir et là la
classe populaire mais 30 fait la même
chose mais avec une communication
beaucoup plus moderne mais aujourd'hui
il veut donner un idéal à l'amérique de
mon point de vue il eût mieux valu qu'il
coopère avec l'ensemble des pays du
monde merci beaucoup pierre picard
d'avoir avec nous avoir apporté votre
analyse
dans quelques instants rester avec mon
nous parlerons cet appel à la grève ont
le premier week-end des vacances de noël
à la sncf des préavis notamment sur les
tgv sud-est et sud-ouest alors les
cheminots ont ils raison de vouloir
faire grève juste avant les fêtes on en
débattra dans quelques instants
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient des nuances
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
un des freins à priori du nucléaire
c'est l'émergence dé nouvelles sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui nous sommes le
pays qui produit l'électricité la pluie
décarbonés au monde on peut rêver à
couvrir toute la planète de d'éoliennes
mais quand ça produit un tiers du temps
que fait-on pour le res d'appui il ya
aussi la démographie ils en sont
toujours à l'afrique quand même avec un
milliard d'habitants en plus la surface
de l'afrique ne sera pas suffisante pour
mettre des panneaux solaires ou sinon ça
se fera au détriment de l'agriculture on
joue aux apprentis sorciers y compris au
niveau européen quand un pays comme
l'allemagne décide du jour là ma
d'arrêter le nucléaire trouvera les
centrales à charbon l'allemagne est le
plus gros pollueurs européens
aujourd'hui le gia qui a sonné l'alarmé
sur les risques du réchauffement
climatique dit bien que les besoins en
électricité sont considérables d'ici
2050 il faudra 50 % de production
électrique en plus comment va-t-on faire
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort devait
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
cette semaine on va passer en revue
l'actualité économique qu'une bonne
partie des économistes qui pensent que
tout ce qui a été fait a été bien fait
que structurellement l'économie va bien
que le chômage a vraiment été vaincue
que le pib a augmenté moi je vois pas où
sont les fondamentaux qui sont bons ben
non justement problème c'est que la
bourse elles montrent simplement parce
que les banques centrales injectent de
l'argent le monde entier sous perfusion
là on a un vrai problème on ne sait pas
comment débrancher la perfusion quand
vous déversez comme ça et que vous
endetter pour faire 5 10 % de déficit
budgétaire
évidemment vous avez un résidu qui
arrive en fibres et en heureusement faut
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles et leur annoncer à chaque fois
que demain l'herbe est plus verte parce
que demain malheureusement l'est rebelle
et
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes
même si mort au maintien de l'ordre et
une catastrophe est tout à fait
déplorable on a vu des personnes
gravement blessées on a entendu aussi le
terme violences policières ce débat sur
les violences policières est ce qu'il a
toujours existé il a toujours existé ou
la première grande manifestation
parisienne du 6 février 34 on a même pu
craindre la disparition de la toute
jeune garde républicaine mobile dans la
presse s'était déchaînée sur ce qui
était réellement le noyau dur du
dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque
et
il ya ces dérives lui classiques basés
sur l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre
terrain de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire 1 c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut et on pouvait la voir
errer 110-80 que sur des phénomènes qui
vont concerner la santé ou
l'alimentation et la crise du coc vide à
renforcer cette nouvelle porte d'entrée
dans les dérives sectaires ou des
groupes vont plutôt parler de
vaccination plutôt parler d'alimentation
plutôt parler de guérison au lieu
d'aller directement sur un terrain qui
sera un terrain religieux ou mystique on
retrouve par exemple dans les dernières
manifestations anti vaccins contre
locaux vides certains éléments qui se
rattachent à des mouvements à tendance
sectaire qui historiquement sont opposés
à toute vaccination
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire cet appel à la grève pour le
premier week-end des vacances de noël à
la sncf des prix après avis notamment
sur les tgv sud-est et sud-ouest des
cheminots réclament des augmentations de
salaires ou encore une prime qu'ovide le
gouvernement court mais de son côté
minoré au maximum la date de cette grève
sur les français alors vous vous
comprenez cette colère des cheminots
qu'il raison faire grève avant les fêtes
on attend vos réactions sur notre compte
et d g
mais avant d'ouvrir le débat sur la
grande social illustration de la
détresse des soignants dans le milieu
hospitalier avec cette fermeture des
urgences de senlis dans l'oise et ce
pour une durée indéterminée
un service qui affiche portes closes
depuis hier à cause d'un manque de
personnel médical et paramédical
une décision prise par l' agence
régionale de santé ce service des
urgences avait déjà été fermé pendant
deux mois en juillet dernier pour les
mêmes raisons tous les malades sont
transférés à creil à une douzaine de
kilomètres pour en parler nous sommes
avec véronique proulx vos guitares
présidente du comité de défense de
l'hôpital de senlis médecins
généralistes bonsoir madame merci d'être
avec nous une situation qu'on imagine
prévisible puisqu'elle avait déjà eu
lieu comment expliquer cette pénurie de
personnel médical récurrentes
winnie bonsoir madame en effet comme
vous le dites ça n'est pas la première
fois puisque cet été pendant deux mois
les urgences ont été fermées pendant
deux mois nuitée joue en permanence et
puis là actuellement depuis lundi donc
depuis hier le service d'urgence est
fermé et également le smur c'est à dire
que le le service mobile d'urgence et de
réanimation et ils vous voulez pour
compléter un peu ce que vous disiez vous
dites que les deux hôpitaux sont sont
proches de 12 km mais en fait l'hôpital
de senlis draine tout le sud-est de luan
est en fait d'aider les habitants qui
sont bien plus éloigné et de douze
kilomètres de l'hôpital de creil puisque
quand on habite nanteuil ou b on est à
peu près à trois quarts d'heure à une
heure de craig vers ce qui est déjà un
hôpital totalement saturé donc ça veut
dire alors bien sûr vous faites bien de
le préciser on parle est effectivement
de la distance à vol d'oiseau entre les
deux hôpitaux mais on imagine bien qu'au
tour et un rayon de plusieurs kilomètres
ça veut dire quoi des conséquences
potentiellement dramatiques pour les
usagers
bien sûr parce que un habitant de
nanteuil par exemple ou 2b ou de tous
ces petits villages du sud f de luan
seront maintenant à une heure de d'un
service d'urgences et c'est à dire que
si vous faites un appart us et bien au
mieux au mieux vous aurez le ca le samu
qui arrivera au bout de le smur qui
arrivera au bout de trois quarts d'heure
une heure donc c'est bien évidemment une
perte de chance pour les habitants bien
évidemment en plus l'hôpital de creil
est déjà totalement saturée donc avoir
encore en plus un surcroît de patients
ces c est absolument insupportable pour
les soignants et également pour les
malades vous avez des personnes âgées
qui attendent des heures voire
quelquefois des jours sur des brancards
aux urgences à creil c'est pas
acceptable au 21e siècle ce n'est pas
acceptable alors la direction elle dit
que les urgences pourrait rouvrir après
le recrutement de trois à quatre
médecins urgentistes qu'est ce qui rend
si compliqué qu'est ce qui empêche ses
recrutements
alors en fait si vous voulez
d'abord trois ou quatre médecins
urgentistes ça ne pourrait pas couvrir
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur fait c'est
pas suffisant et d'autre part
le si vous voulez depuis que l'hôpital
de senlis et fusionner avec l'hôpital de
creil quand vous travaillez à senlis on
peut vous envoyer travailler axa et
puisque c'est le même hôpital et c'est
très difficile pour les jambes accepter
ça
certains l'acceptent mais d'autres ne
l'acceptent pas parce que ils ont
l'impression que c'est un certain mépris
de la part de la direction et puis qu'on
les prend pour des pions pour des
gauches trou et vous voulez ça ne donne
pas instance cela ne donne pas un sens à
leur travail de se retrouver comme ça
d'un seul coup balancer d'un hôpital à
un autre d'un service à un autre et
c'est très mal vécu par là par le
personnel on imagine que vous vous êtes
bien évidemment rapprocher de la
direction de la santé qui a pris agences
régionales de santé qui a pris cette
décision qu est ce qu on vous répond est
aujourd'hui quelle quelle est l'issue
l'issue je pense que si le
si les habitants ne se mobilise pas
si les élus ne se mobilise pas je pense
que la fermeture des urgences sera
entérinée par l' agence régionale de
santé et on en parlera plus voilà pense
que c'est ça qui va se passer il faut
absolument que les habitants se
mobilisent
que les élus se mobilisent et pas que
pat lemaire qui commence seulement à se
mobiliser mais tous les élus de tous les
villages du bassin de vie de qui est
drainée par l'hôpital de senlis c'est à
dire fort mille habitants il faut que
tout le monde se mobilise en plus on est
en période préélectorale donc il faut
que tout le monde se mobilise au en
période électorale qui on se mobilise ça
va faire bouger les choses
merci beaucoup veronica prévaut à bitar
présidente du comité de défense de
l'hôpital de senlis merci de nous avoir
apporté votre témoignage
et le malaise d'un autre secteur les
syndicats des secteurs de l'animation et
du périscolaire en grève aujourd'hui et
demain au coeur des revendications une
hausse significative des salaires les
syndicats souhaitent aussi la création
d'un vrai statut pour mettre fin à toute
forme de précarité
les grévistes se retrouveront demain
pour un rassemblement devant le
ministère de l'éducation nationale à 13h
aujourd'hui s'étaient donné rendez vous
devant les mérites parking
actuel salarié peut se voir monter
certaines travaillent mais c'est une
négation du progrès social de la bande
de progrès social d'autre part c'est
encore plus grave dans la fonction
publique où les salaires sont pas on
subit déjà le gel du point d'indicé dix
ans donc c'est une dégradation de
l'attractivité s'est littéralement se
met à tuer la fonctionnalité en fait
aujourd'hui il ya un problème de
recrutement parce que les salaires mon
collègue le disait justement ils n'ont
pas été augmentés le point d'indicé est
gelé depuis 20 ans et aujourd'hui on ne
recrute plus parce que nous les salaires
et sont deux fois moins élevé que dans
le privé on est en train de supprimer
nos jours de congé dans le même temps
ils externalisent toute une série de
savoir faire ils sont en train de
préparer la privatisation de quantité de
mission et privatisent d'ores et déjà
toute une série de missions donc
effectivement il ya de moins en moins de
personnes qui veulent venir travailler à
la ville de paris et c'est malheureux on
le déplore et on combat justement c'est
cette politique est toujours au chapitre
social de nombreux appels à la grève sur
les lignes tgv et ter sont à prévoir
pour le premier week-end des vacances de
noël les lignes tgv sud ouest et
atlantique sont concernées dans la
région parisienne la circulation des rer
sera également fortement perturbé dès ce
vendredi une grève des cheminots à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats pour
réclamer notamment des hausses de
salaires l'amélioration des conditions
de travail et une prime qu'ovide alors
malgré
les départs en vacances possiblement
perturbé à noël ou prenez vous cette
colère des cheminots t-il raison faire
grève avant les fêtes on attend toujours
vos réactions sur notre compte
télégramme et place au face à face
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler thomas
porte mon nom du parlement de l'union
populaire bonsoir thomas porte merci
d'être avec nous vous connaissez bien ce
métier de cheminot on va en reparler
maxence briquet porte parole du parti à
la reconquête la reconquête d'eric
zemmour merci d'être avec nous également
les syndicats dont qu'ils réclament on
l'a entendu l'amélioration des
conditions de travail des embauches une
prime qu'ovide on peut parler réellement
d'une dégradation des conditions de
travail accentuée par la crise sanitaire
également dans ce secteur thomas porte
qu'est ce qu'il y a de pire dans ce
secteur par rapport aux autres mais ya
beaucoup de choses qui se courait le
c'est aussi pour ça qu'à une colère
sociale sncf parce que ça fait des mois
que la direction refuse d'ouvrir des
négociations salariales de haut niveau
et à la sncf les salaires sont gelés
depuis huit ans donc huit années
consécutives sans augmentation de
salaire alors que l'inflation augmenté y
compris même le smic augmente et si on a
calculé par exemple la rémunération des
dix plus hauts dirigeants de la sncf en
2019 s'est quasiment trente mille euros
par mois soit neuf fois le salaire des
cheminots donc c'est absolument
scandaleux il ya eu des conditions de
travail dégradées puisqu'on a envoyé les
cheminots quand même travaillé pendant
le confinement pour assurer le service
public et c'est tout à fait normal mais
aujourd'hui ils demandent une
reconnaissance puisqu'ils ont été
travaillés au départ sans masquer son
gant c'était absolument dangereuse qui
se passait aujourd'hui demande une
ouverture de négociations pour des
hausses des salaires une prime qu'ovide
et aussi des embauches parce qu'on n'en
parle pas souvent mais il ya des tgv qui
sont aujourd'hui bondé et qui circulait
qu'un seul contrôleur à bord et c'est
pas sérieux au niveau de sécurité donc
c'est aussi une réponse qu'on les
besoins des usagers maxence fabriquer
vous comprenez vous cette colère des
cheminots quand on entend thomas porte
nous décrire cette situation huit ans de
gel des salaires mais monsieur porte
sous les 20 points importants c'est
beaucoup les cheminots ont vraiment rimé
ils ont travaillé durant la crise
sanitaire
maintenant on n'est pas spécialement
favorable au fait d' augmenter certaines
catégories de travailleurs et pas les
autres c'est à dire que les mesures pour
le pouvoir d'achat que propose eric
zemmour ça a vocation à toucher toute la
population française lorsqu'on parle de
défiscalisation de la participation
lorsqu'on parle de baisse de la csg pour
les salaires situés entre le smic et
2000 euros il ya une réelle volonté de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
ça ne touchera pas que les cheminots ça
touchera l'ensemble de la population
lors ce point de vue là c'est de notre
côté une réelle préoccupation après on
déplore forcément le fait que cette
grève interviennent à une période
pareille où les français ont quand même
trimé pendant toute l'année ils se
retrouvent dans une situation où les
périodes de noël sont quand même un des
rares moments il peut surtout en famille
pour souffler un coup et là ils se font
embêté par des syndicalistes qui
défendent leurs intérêts corporatistes
absolument pas les intérêts des
cheminots photo ma porte vous comprenez
cet argument parce que c'est vrai que
même gabriel atteint cet après-midi
affirmé que les cheminots ont déjà eu
une prime de voir d'achat de 300 à 600
euros mise en place par la sncf
vrai ou faux est ce qu'il ya un cas
particulier cheminots ou tout simplement
ils ont peut-être un pouvoir de pression
qui est plus élevé que d'autres secteurs
parce qu un soignant qui se met en grève
on imagine voilà les conséquences sur la
santé mais enfin là ça embête les
vacances certes on nous ressort toujours
l'argument de que ça dérange les usagers
quand on fait grève mais quelques sur la
période à chaque fois on a cet argument
là mais moi j'ai envie de renverser la
charge de la responsabilité si la
direction de la sncf avait répondu
revendications des salariés du rail sur
les augmentations de salaires on aurait
pas de mobilisation sociale pour les
fêtes de noël parce qu'on fait pas grève
par plaisir parce que hein ça coûte de
l'argent et on sait que ça va pénaliser
des usagers mais c'est pas simplement
des intérêts corporatistes je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les cheminots qui se
mobilisent c'est aussi sur des questions
qu'un jean rappelle qu'il faut des
contrôleurs à bord c'est des questions
de sécurité et ça concerne aussi les
gens qui prennent les trains on a une
dégradation avec l'ouverture à la
concurrence et la privatisation du rail
on pourra en parler mais tout ça mis
bout à bout mais qu'aujourd'hui on a un
service à bout de souffle mais c'est pas
le secteur le seul secteur public qui
souffre qui souffrent pardon vous avez
eu un reportage juste avant sur les
urgences à saint lys on voit que partout
le service public est attaqué par ce
gouvernement qu'il ya des restrictions
budgétaires des suppressions de postes
qui mettent en danger les populations et
qui dégradent les conditions de travail
des salariés donc c'est la mobilisation
elle est aujourd'hui nécessaire et moi
je leur apporte évidemment de tout mon
soutien
max a expliqué sur cette dégradation
effectivement des services publics
les cheminots le pouvoir peut-être de
nuisance entre guillemets le pouvoir de
faire bouger les choses est ce que d'une
certaine manière est une forme de
légitimité à l'utiliser quand on est
entre guillemets maltraité la situation
de base il faut quand même la pause et
c'est à dire que le cncf est une
entreprise qui a énormément de
difficultés financières qui avant la
reprise de sa dette de 50 5 milliards
par l'état à hauteur de 35 milliards
entre 2020 et 2022 permettez sur
l'entreprise qui donne une situation
d'aléa moral c'est à dire qu'on a des
très mauvais choix stratégique
d'investissement qui ont été faits
pendant les trente quarante dernières
années aujourd'hui tout le monde en paie
les pots cassés les usagers en premier
chef
pour une raison assez simple c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
gebre la table ça me fait un peu rire sa
réaction globale ne doit pas prendre le
métro tous les jours c'est à dire qu'il
se rend bien compte que des transports
parisiens par exemple c'est tout le
temps bondé et dans les trains là ce
sera abondé à cause des cheminots mais
ceux qui en pâtissent le plus ce sont
les français de la france périphérique
qui eux aujourd'hui sont ceux qui
doivent prendre le train pour le thé
vert outrancière pour venir travailler
dans les grandes métropoles qu'ils
prennent pendant une heure une heure et
demie qui sont systématiquement
pénalisés par ça et qui aujourd'hui vont
se retrouver face à une grève qui encore
une fois peut porter des intérêts
légitimes a pas de sujet là dessus mais
qui est menée par des syndicalistes et
particulièrement des cégétistes qui
aujourd'hui ne représente plus personne
il y avait 45 % de français syndiqués en
1950 aujourd'hui à -2 7 % sont des gens
qui ne représentent qu'eux mêmes et
qu'ils emmerdent les français comme
c'est georges pompidou l'emmerdement ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui est propre à
l'état et à l'inflation normative c'est
quelque chose qui peut aussi s'appliquer
aux corps intermédiaires qui eux
aujourd'hui jouissent d'un pouvoir ou
ceux la roche en tout cas de manière
complètement démesuré thomas porte à cet
argument une petite partie des
syndicaliste cégétiste qui représentent
qu'eux mêmes vous qui connaissez bien
cette entreprise est ce que c'est le cas
où est ce
grande majorité des salariés sont
d'accord avec le déjà il n'a pas fallu
attendre longtemps à ce débat pour
l'extrême-droite et insultait les
syndicats donc on voit évidemment
convention est une équipe dure à
détricoter il se place mais oui mais bon
j'ai aucun souci a qualifié eric zemmour
d'extrême droite et quand on voit les
gens qui l'entourent école et que ça me
vois très peu de sujets à débat et
aujourd'hui les syndicats la cgt
notamment à la sncf et la ratp sont
confortés aux élections professionnelles
la cgt est la première organisation
représentative et ce préavis de grève il
est pas simplement déposé par la cgt est
déposée par sud rail et par l'uimm ça
donc on voit qu'il ya une unité
syndicale sur ces questions là parce
qu'aujourd'hui les cheminotes et
cheminots qu'ils soient syndiqués
d'ailleurs ou pas sont mobilisés parce
que leurs conditions de travail se
dégradent et ils se mobilisent pour
augmenter les salaires et avoir des
conditions de travail qui permet
d'assurer la sécurité des usagers c'est
ça la réalité aussi non mais c'est ce
que vous dites c'est que tous les
syndicats sont mobilisés mais ça fait
tous personnes au total ça peut faire
tous les syndicats si vous voulez une
représentent personne ne savait de
regard mais sur la mie de pain anigo lui
connaît monsieur pour le coup moi je
passe ma vie à discuter avec des gens
qui bossent moi serait de l'immobilité
aussi donc je sais de quoi je parle je
suis vous êtes cheminots donc là dessus
je pense qu'on peut être sur un pied
d'égalité moi aujourd'hui vous me dites
que je suis d'extrême droite définissent
et l'extrême droite l'idéologie fasciste
c'est ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui eric
zemmour d'accord d'accord et vous ce que
vous avez déjà eu des livres qui parlent
du fascisme est ce qu'on sait c'est que
même chez les dames en salle et c'est
dingue que vous avez pas mis beaucoup de
temps non plus à insulter les gens de
fasciste parce que oui vous êtes aussi
aux observateurs de l'extrême droite
c'est ça c'est assez dingue quand même
devoir acquitter quand vous
laissez moi de venir de social on la
connaît monsieur attaqué de la même s'il
vous plaît au bout d'un moment parce que
6ème à des décisions de justice juste
deux points le premier point c'est que
vous participer aujourd'hui à des
travaux des pseudos travaux à
l'observateur de l'extrême droite qui
vise à combattre des chimères l'extrême
droite je vous le dis vous n'avez pas su
répondre c'est une droite qui est anti
parlementarisme et anti-républicaine
aujourd'hui elle n'existe plus vous
combattez des chimères monsieur eric
zemmour il combat l'islamisme
aujourd'hui il est menacé tous les jours
comme ça extrait je
reviens et je rende les propositions sur
le sujet je reviens c'est majeur
audience je reviens mais l'enjeu j'y
viens je vis un deuxième point sur le
programme du ferroviaire le programme
des transports j'ai vu que vous étiez
pour le fait de remettre le fret
ferroviaire en avant nous sommes pour
j'ai vu que vous étiez pour le fait de
revitaliser les petites lignes nous
sommes pour je vous écris pour le fait
de favoriser l'intermodalité notamment
pour les trajets domicile travail
nous sommes pour vous pensé exactement
comme eric zemmour monsieur vous voyez
vous dit qu'on n'a pas trop bien vous
dites qu'on a pas d'idées mais en fait
si c'est juste vous qui vous drapez
comme ça dans votre défense de l'intérêt
général comme si vous étiez celui qui
défendait la veuve et l'orphelin alors
que vous ne représentez que vous m'aimez
vous ne défendez personnes on va écouter
gabriela talent justement qui a réagi à
cette annonce de préavis de grève qu'ils
ont regretté ce choix écouté par parole
du gouvernement
je souhaite minoré au maximum l'impact
de cette grève pour les français ils ont
envie de pouvoir se retrouver en famille
à noël on n'a pas spécialement envie non
plus de se retrouver dans des trains
bondés en période qu'ovide parce qu'il
ya moins de trains pour se déplacer
thomas porte 4 réactions sur un gabriel
attal vous allez être d'accord de
nouveau avec maxence fabriqué il doit
pas prendre souvent le métro parce que
c'est vrai qu'on n'attend pas les grèves
pour être un petit peu bondé dans le
métro parisien notamment les leçons de
gabriella talent sur le service public
et sur l'état du réseau il peut se les
garder parce que le gouvernement fait
partie de ceux qui ont cassé le rail
public aussi et notamment la réforme des
moniales macro sur le ferroviaire
publique mais on n'a pas attendu que les
cheminots se mobilisent contre les
conditions salariales pour que les
transports sont bondées c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'on dénonce depuis des mois pour
organiser ce qu'on appelle avec jean luc
mélenchon une société du roulement qui
permettent aux salariés de prendre des
transports qui soit abondé alors qu'on
sait que le virus circule dans ces
endroits là et quand vous prenez le
métro chaque matin à paris vous rendez
bien compte que c'est hallucinant qu'on
entasse les gens on va regarder j'étais
un petit coup d'oeil quelques réponses
télégramme
voilà des téléspectateurs non c'est pas
ça voilà la question grogne sociale
ont-ils raison de faire la grève avant
les fêtes oui parce qu'ils ne sont pas
écoutés sans cela mais la gratuité des
voyages ou la garantie qu'il n'y aura
pas de contrôle de billet mettrait plus
la pression notamment vous êtes d'accord
avec cette proposition ça mettrait plus
la pression justement le contrôle des
billets michel qui nous dit aussi s'y
faire la grève changer les choses ça
serait interdit de faire grève maxence
briquets non mais si
si ces réactions la démontre bien le
réel malaise qu'il y a je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut quand même
légitimement s'interroger sur ce qui est
proposé typiquement emparé de la
gratuité des trajets aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on regarde le modèle de
financement des transports publics c'est
quelque chose qui est faisable c'est
déjà des transports qui sont largement
subventionnés tous tendance à augmenter
le métro oui oui maintenant mais la
question c'est pas à l'augmentation du
prix du ticket qui à mon sens peut se
justifier c'est la part que paient
réellement l'usagé dans le prix final du
trajet c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez les entreprises qui contribuent au
travers du versement mobilité vous avez
les collectivités locales qui abondent
dans le budget des autorités
organisatrices des mobilités vous avez
tous à tout un organisme public tout un
écosystème qui financent le système de
transport on a un bon système de
transport notamment de l'urbain
l'interurbain le système ferroviaire
tombe en désuétude faute
d'investissements à cause du tout tgv
qui a miné la dette de la sncf
aujourd'hui il ya trop peu
d'investissements il faut en refaire
pour le développement territorial pour
faire du développement économique de
l'est campagne donc on va dire
revitaliser les petites lignes favoriser
l'intermodalité et ça crée des emplois
tout ça vous avez des tas d emplois de
l'industrie française vous avez la
possibilité d'embaucher des gens à la
sncf aussi lorsqu'il ya besoin de
contrôleurs dans les tgv ça c'est des
choses qu'on propose avec eric zemmour
pour 2022 donc vous êtes d'accord thomas
porte il reste une cadence et celui du
service public je suis pas sûr que eric
zemmour sur le premier garant et le
premier défenseur du service public j'ai
jamais vu prendre la défense de salariés
qui sont mobilisés pour la grève mais je
vais répondre ce qui a été dit sur le la
boucle télégramme si la greffe servent à
quelque chose on l'aurait interdite il y
avait quasiment 50% des français même
plus ce qu'ils étaient opposés à la
réforme des retraites à l'époque et on a
tous avaient soutenu les cheminots qui
étaient en première ligne pour s'opposer
à cette réforme là qui avait créé des
inégalités donc aujourd'hui ils sont
mobilisés pour défendre des conditions
de travail mais aussi défendre les
conditions d'usagé aujourd'hui quand
vous entendez gabriel talbot il faut
minoré au maximum l'impact de ces grèves
finalement quelle marge de manoeuvre
pour le gouvernement aujourd'hui pour le
coup gabriela talent
je suis d'accord avec vous on se
passerait bien c'est le sont c'est à
dire que tous ces problèmes là c'est lui
qui les a causé c'est une gestion très
mauvaise de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement et aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec le un pompier pyromane qui
est devant le fait accompli on a
l'impression d'un enfant bea qui a pas
vraiment compris que toutes les
mauvaises routes blanches et noires
mauvaises décisions qu'il a prises à les
mener à cette situation là donc
forcément on déplore qu'on en soit
arrivé là que les français soient à la
fois matraqués par l'écrivain par la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et par les
grèves ça va être compliqué pour eux je
pense pour ceux qui vont voir se
déplacer en train pour noël et on espère
que ça se fera au mieux et en espérant
que le lac rond ne soit pas réélu en
2022 pour qu'enfin il ya du changement
dans ce domaine thomas porte vous dites
gel des salaires depuis huit ans alors
on sait qu'il n'ya pas eu que des grèves
pour la revalorisation des salaires et
beaucoup de grève sur les retraites mais
enfin ça veut dire que quoi que la
situation ne s'est pas du tout améliorée
au fil des années avec toutes les
greffes qui a eu du côté
s'est pas améliorée puisque les salaires
qui sont gelés sur 8 ans née consécutive
ya peu aujourd'hui de profession qui
subit ça alors que l'inflation gelé
rappelé tout l'art augmente et que le
coût de la vie et le prix de l'énergie
toutes ces questions-là augmenter les
cheminots comme les autres qui subissent
ces prix là donc il ya eu mais les
attaques auraient été majeur sur la sncf
elles ont pas été simplement sur les
salaires on a une ouverture la
concurrence qui va entraîner une
dégradation du réseau comme ce qu'on a
connus par exemple en grande-bretagne on
a cette ouverture à la concurrence qui
va dégrader le service qui va remettre
en cause les conditions de travail et
aujourd'hui si on a des territoires
entiers notamment les gilet jaune qui
avait dénoncé dans la mobilisation le
droit à la mobilité c'est qu'on a laissé
des pans entiers du territoire
s'entraîne aujourd'hui et sans aucun
moyen de transport un jour je rebondis
juste sous ce qui a été dit justement
sur le fait que les cheminots eu un gel
de salaire depuis huit ans typiquement
ce que vous posez les zemmour sur encore
une fois le fait de défiscaliser la
participation des entreprises c'est
quelque chose qui va fortement augmenter
leur pouvoir d'achat eux parce que la
sncf est une entreprise qui jusqu'à 2018
faisait des bénéfices donc le fait de
défiscaliser la participation ça va
inciter encore une fois les cheminots a
plus participé l'entreprise a plus
impliqué dedans et ça ne peut être que
bénéfique pour les scènes cfa terme
merci beaucoup si thomas porte merci
également avec 105 et d'avoir été avec
nous
et dans le reste de l'actualité le
départ aujourd'hui de tombouctou des
soldats de l'armée française huit ans
après leur arrivée au mali des troupes
françaises ont quitté la base avancée de
cette ville rendu à l'armée locale un
départ donc après kidal et tessa lite et
qui marque un tournant fort c'est à
tombouctou que l'opération barkan avait
démarré en 2013 sous la présidence de
françois hollande
et aurait sur le continent africain pour
parler de la politique en tunisie le
président kaïs et dévoilé une feuille de
route jusqu'à l'élection d'un nouveau
parlement dans un an le gel du parlement
est prolongé jusqu'en décembre 2022 date
de nouvelles élections législatives à
tunis bcm chebbi sur place
ses prises de parole sont rares et
pourtant il ya soir à la surprise
générale le président ça y est s'est
adressé à la nation à l'issue d'un
conseil des ministres sur la situation
politique et économique du pays prévu
initialement le 17 décembre ce discours
est venu ôter les doutes et rumeurs qui
circulaient autour d'une possible
dissolution du parlement gelé depuis le
25 juillet dernier date du coup de force
du chef de l'état dans un discours d'un
peu moins d'une heure le président
tunisien est revenu sur son projet pour
la tunisie sa lutte contre la corruption
sa volonté de sortir de cette impasse au
plus vite en invitant les tunisiens à
continuer de le soutenir malgré un
contexte politico-social des plus
moroses le chef de l'état a fini par
annoncer les contours de son projet en
sept points dont les plus importants
l'organisation d'un référendum portant
sur une réforme de la constitution et la
tenue de nouvelles élections est
législatif écouter kaïs saïd
sadi
premièrement le parlement reste
suspendue je n'ai jusqu'à la date de
l'organisation de nouvelles élections
et deuxièmement l'organisation de
consultations populaires jarretière
début janvier
certains préparatifs ont déjà commencé
pour les plateformes électroniques et
pour les questions qui seront posées qui
seront claires et courtes
réforme constitutionnelle et d'autres
projets sur la famille un référendum en
25 juillet date de la commémoration
la déclaration a arraché
un gel du parlement prolongé pour
minimum un an ce qui permettra à kaïs
ier de demeurer le seul maître à bord
d'un système politique à la dérive le
chef de l'état demeure le réel détenteur
du pouvoir exécutif au grand dam de
l'opposition vent debout contre ce
qu'elle qualifie de dérive autoritaire
déterminés à ne rien lâcher le locataire
du palais de carthage a répété qu'il n'y
aura aucun retour en arrière message
clair adressé à tous ceux qui l'ont
accusé d'avoir fait subir la tunisie un
coup d'état constitutionnel est une
atteinte aux acquis de la révolution
2011 malgré un climat des plus
incertains marqué par une hausse du
chômage de l'insécurité et du coût de la
vie est les tunisiens veulent y croire
selon un sondage de l'agencé sigma
conseil du 14 décembre dernier 62% des
tunisiens continuent de faire confiance
à l'action du président sayed et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez vous demain dès 20
heures d'ici là n'oubliez pas de réagir
et d'actualité continue toute la soirée
sur arte france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre ou la
peuplent c'était une volonté collectés
vous savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
pic il est clair que tout le monde
attend sable
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
les gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la louve
ligue parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est on dirait qu'il y
a quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir amitié
[Musique]
c'était une figure nationale il